we have this from The Washington Post
why 17 billion dollars in Credit Suisse
bonds became worthless I don't care
about Credit Suisse it's a big bank it's
imploding UBS what is that United
banking system or something like that I
don't want to check I think Union or
something let's just double check
because I was I forget
what is it
it's not telling me it's not telling you
you look at this group yeah it's got to
be just do UBS Wiki bro anyway Bank of
Switzerland Union Bank of Switzerland
you see there you go They're gonna buy
us formerly the Union Bank of
Switzerland then they changed it to UBS
I see but what is okay it used to stand
for something now it just stands for UBS
so so UPS is going to buy Credit Suisse
but their bonds are worthless what
people are basically saying is that the
whole system is collapsing and we have
this tweet from Balaji which is very
shocking to the point where it's got a
lot of people angry
he says
I will uh so so James Medlock says I
will bet anyone one million dollars the
U.S does not enter hyperinflation
Balaji says I will take that bet now
this guy is the former CTO of coinbase
which is a crypto exchange he says you
buy one Bitcoin I will send one million
dollars in USD
This is 40 to 1 odds as one Bitcoin is
worth 26 000 it's currently like 28. the
term is 90 days all we need is a
mutually agreed custodian who will still
be there to settle this in the event of
digital dollar devaluation he is saying
outright
he thinks
that one Bitcoin will be worth one
million dollars in three months
and the argument is he shows these
graphs about
Federal Reserve weekly remittances to
treasury look at this going back to
2011. even when things were bad they
weren't this bad
whoa look at uh unrealized gains and
losses even when they were bad it was
never this bad
he's got another one showing all the
same things and we already saw that
other uh with this other tweet that we
talked about last week that said the
bond market is predict believes the
system has already collapsed
if that's the case what he's arguing is
people think we live in an analog world
it's exactly how he says it
and that means
analog takes a long time
but we're not in that world anymore it's
digital information transmission is
instant which means it's either one or
it's zero everybody knows it happened or
nobody knows it happened back in the day
if there was a market collapse the only
people who knew were the people at the
market they're in the stock exchange
going what's happening then they they
send Pony writers out with letters to
inform the investors who then Panic
there's I can't remember what show I was
watching
or a movie or something where a guy goes
to withdraw money in California but the
bank has shut down and so he has to race
the bank Messengers to a Northern Bank
to beat the message the idea is the
company's freezing withdrawals because
they're going out of business or
something like that's happening bank's
collapsing so the bank he goes he says
sorry sir you can't have your money
because we're shutting down
he then has to get to a northern branch
which is like three hours ride before
the messenger gets there because if he
gets there first he'll withdraws money
then the messenger comes and shuts it
down that's how it used to it's crazy
today before you even know they've
already made a phone call
so what's going to happen when people
finally realize the banks are bust it's
going to be near instantaneous that the
dollar breaks that's his bet a lot of
people are calling him crazy because for
Bitcoin to reach one million dollars in
three months I told them I'll take his
bet my worst here's what I'll do I said
I'll buy two Bitcoin fifty six thousand
dollars it's 50 what is it it's at 27 29
28 right now 28. so 56 000 and my worst
case scenario is when when I lose one of
those Bitcoin I'll get a million dollars
for my 56 000. I'm not gonna cry about
it right so that's why I'm like I can't
believe those odds is is he saying I
he's saying I will send he will send one
million he made it bet with this guy so
I hit him up we're gonna we're gonna try
and do some kind of we might I might do
a show with him for the culture War
we'll figure it out but he is saying
that he is going to put up one million
dollars cash
for one Bitcoin
that's that that's the wager because
he's betting the buying power of the
dollar becomes trash and the Bitcoin
becomes worth a million I think he's
attempting to instill confidence when
you talk about economics confidence is
the backbone of the economic system and
people don't believe in the currency
they won't use it and it loses value so
he's attempting to create value for
Bitcoin but I think it sounds freaking
insane he's asking for a 10 40 times
increase in the value of Bitcoin in the
next 90 days 40 times increase so a lot
of people are saying he's trying to
create a self-fulfilling prophecy by
making this bet he's gotten a ton of
attention what's the traffic on the
Tweet I'm curious 11.5 million views
there's traffic on it yeah and there's a
bunch of news stories have been written
about it because
he he said he he told me he's doing it
he is going to put up the million
dollars in cash the dude's probably
worth several hundred million or
whatever he's an early Bitcoin investor
so he's probably very loaded and can
easily afford to do the million dollars
but this guy needs only to bet 26
thousand dollars
for a chance to win one million is that
a bet worth taking it does he lose the
Bitcoin to the guy if it doesn't yes
appreciate it that's the point
of money you don't have no no no no no
no no no he doesn't lose it oh well then
the worst case scenario is you still
have your Bitcoin in 90 days no no no no
no no no no listen listen
Balaji Wagers one million in cash and
this guy James Medlock wages one Bitcoin
and then the winner takes both yes I see
right yeah don't don't bet money you
don't have you don't you don't take both
you just don't lose what you have you
know what I mean so if the guy buys a
Bitcoin and it stays at thirty thousand
dollars in 90 days he gets a million
bucks
so so what's what's what's what's what's
what's the downside is he gonna take
this is he's doing this deal with more
than one person or is this just like a
person he said you know here's here's
the thing he said he was going to do it
with two two people
uh he said I will do it with Medlock and
one other person sufficient to prove the
point so I reached out to him and said
bro I'll do it and I don't even disagree
with you about Bitcoin and the banks I
just disagree on the 90 days thing did
he respond to you he said he's only
going to do with this one guy but he'll
come on and we'll talk about it which I
think would be really great however I
don't think he's in the U.S so we've got
ah we'll try and figure something out I
was like maybe we can do something for
the culture War podcast where you know
or I'll just do a short segment for
timcast news because I think talking to
him about this is is important so he's
making this bet with one person am I am
I just yeah I'm just making this clear
one person okay one person and that
person's already been selected it's the
guy who said we're not going to enter
hyperinflation okay okay I don't care
about the Bitcoin thing look if you
don't care about Bitcoin ignore this
it's fine but what you should care about
is is the data he provides on the
banking system collapse
so of course his whole perspective is
Bitcoin is better
but what he's showing in terms of his of
his sources is the unrealized losses and
massive collapse of treasuries bonds and
the banking system yeah this is the
collapse you wonder if things are going
to collapse we are in the collapse right
now that is why banks are buying other
banks that is a sign of the collapse
that's the bailouts this is what people
don't realize either UBS buying Credit
Suisse is the bailout yeah this is
what's going to happen here's my
prediction
you got First Republic Bank is is
crumbling the shares dropped again like
35 bounce to minus eight it was like
minus 35 then minus 18. there's a
despite the fact they're gonna do a 30
billion dollar infusion despite the fact
that the Fed was going to put in what I
think like 2 trillion or something
what's gonna happen is a bank will buy
the failing bank and they'll say see it
got bought out then the FED will issue
their easing or loans to the bank who
made the purchase as a way of doing a
workaround bailout instead of doing a
direct government bailout or a direct
fed bailout a private bank will make the
purchase and they'll say no there's no
banks collapsing they were just
mismanaged and this powerful Private
Bank bought them up there's nothing
actually here making it stronger and
then that private bank behind the scene
says okay fed Pony up and the fat would
be like printing the money as we speak
and they give them a bigger loan because
their new valuation with the new
acquisition of the new bank makes their
company worth more money this is the UBS
is actually a result of a merger that's
why they went from uh Union Bank of
Switzerland in 1998 they bought Swiss
Bank Corporation became UBS I think this
global bank conglomeration things
massively dangerous uh because it gives
a small group of people the ability to
turn off your money so let's let's let's
yes yeah let's play a game real quick
21 Bitcoin right now is at twenty eight
thousand you said yeah and it is
unfathomable to us that it could reach
one million dollars in 90 days I mean
maybe a hundred thousand because it was
at sixty something it's Peak last time
but what if I were to say this
what if I were to say not that Bitcoin
is going to go from twenty six thousand
to one million ninety days what if I was
to say the second and third largest
banking collapse in U.S history would
happen within two days of each other
would you believe that you'd say what in
two days
the the second and third biggest banking
collapse imagine if he came out before
Silicon Valley Bank collapsed when
silvergate first broke and he said I
will bet you
one million dollars in cash you put up
26 000 I put up one million if I'm right
I get 26 if you're right you get a
million in two days the second and third
largest banking collapses in history
will happen who would not take that bet
they'd be like you think hit two two
black swanimate two historical moments
are gonna happen in two days
I'll do that bet I'm gonna win a million
bucks and then you'd lose 20 grand you
lose 25 Grand I think it's if I think
it's more likely that Wells Fargo
collapses on Friday than it is that
Bitcoin is a million dollars a night it
is I think it's more likely we're going
to see the biggest bank in the world
collapse than Bitcoin go to because what
they're gonna they're gonna artificially
control the value of Bitcoin they're
gonna Jack it up then there's going to
be a bunch of people will buy then all
the top dollars will sell off then it'll
drop again and the whole time they'll be
getting ready to switch out your US
dollars for U.S Central Bank coins so
you're not gonna have to worry about
dollars and then they're gonna make
Bitcoin look like a bad guy and they
make the usdc look awesome the digital
currency is like maybe even if they
didn't hit a million dollars it would be
there for like a week and then it would
fall to 300 yeah
jacket up to 60 again and then all these
people will buy and they're like I
missed the boat it'll be 80 and then the
huge sell-off I mean I that's what
they've been doing is I don't know the
scary thing is if Bitcoin starts rising
to a million rapidly then a bunch of
people buy in and then it drops to 40.
and then everyone's dead broke and they
say C is the problem of crypto you need
a stable cryptocurrency that we can
moderate create a depression bring in a
new banking system federal reserves
digital crypto Asset Management fund and
then they say for all those who saw
tremendous losses due to bitcoin we will
be issuing U.S digital coin fed coin
so that you can you know have some money
back as a major bailout to the Working
Class People every liberal will be like
the government should bail these people
out Bitcoin was a scam the whole time
and we've all been saying it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time